ARTURS VITOLS: OK,
my name is Arturs.
ROSS SMITH: And I'm Ross.
Good morning.
ARTURS VITOLS: I'm a
designer at Willowbrite.
Ross is a programmer.
And we're going to do a
talk about Dart at 60 FPS.
Probably most of you
have figured out already
that this talk is going to be
about games-- game development,
to be more specific.
And we're going to talk about
mobile game development.
A little bit about
ourselves-- we
have done mobile
game development
in the past, me and Ross.
But this is our first
project together.
So it makes things a
bit more interesting.
We decided to go
on a little quest.
For this time, we wanted
to make the game that
is as performant as possible.
So we wanted to go on
a quest of performance.
And to make the
quest interesting,
you need challenges.
To make the quest interesting,
And so we needed to set out
challenges for ourselves.
But before we could do
that, the challenges got us.
A member of our team, very early
on the project, broke his arm.
And actually, that is
a pretty huge drawback
because he was a programmer.
And so we decided we
need to cheer him up.
In video games you cheer up
a person by giving a power-up
or giving some health
bars or stuff like that.
But in real life,
we are not medics.
We can't help him.
So we had to figure out
some way to emotionally help
the guy to feel better and to
help ourselves to feel better.
So we made simple
get better cards
or get well cards--
say as you like.
And that's a very short story,
how our first two characters
were born for the game.
So let's go back to the
challenges of performance.
Let's go back to
the performance.
So we decided to set out
challenges for ourselves.
First challenge for
us was the memory.
A lot of my friends have
Android phones, and most of them
have low-end Android phones.
And they all have
the same problem,
is that they have very low
memory for the phone memory.
And they can't install
anything on the phone.
They have to delete
something to install again
the new app or game.
So we set a goal that even
though their phone memory is
full, we still have to squeeze
in our game on their phones.
So even though they think
they can't install it,
they still can do it.
So there's some
more research, we
decided that our game has to
be less than 20 megabytes.
The next challenge is
performance for us.
So here's the
exhibit A, my phone,
which is Sony Ericsson Xperia.
And it's a pretty old phone.
And I never actually
been able-- I've been
developing games for awhile.
And I never been able to play
them on my phone because it
has only a single-core
1 gigahertz CPU.
And for the first
time, I actually
wanted to develop
a game that can
be played either on high-end
devices and on low-end devices.
So we set ourselves a goal.
So the game has to
run on single-core 1
gigahertz CPU as well
as the high-end devices.
The next challenge was loading.
We knew that the
loading has to be fast.
We really didn't know.
We didn't have any preferences
how fast it should be.
So we just said
it has to be fast.
We'll know when we
see it if it's fast.
The next thing we
wanted to achieve
was unique look and unique feel.
We're going to
return to that later.
So I'll give the stage
to Ross, my friend.
Yep.
ROSS SMITH: So as
Arturs has shown you,
we had kind of some pretty
specific goals for this game
in terms of performance
and also in terms
of the design of the game.
So we know that in order
to reach that goal,
we were going to have to build
some custom tools for our game.
And we pretty much had
decided that at the beginning.
So the next step was to choose
what technology are we going
to use to build these tools.
And our first instinct
was, OK, well,
maybe we're going to use
.NET and the C# language
that's widely used
for game tools.
And there's a good
reason for that.
It's awesome technology.
But we had this idea that for
mobile games in particular
that there could be an
even better solution.
And we thought that that was
Dart and the web platform.
So I'm going to talk about a few
of the larger challenges we had
in making our game.
And I'll tell you about how
Dart and the web platform
kind of really aligned with our
solutions to those challenges.
So the first issue was
the issue of graphics.
Now, a lot of mobile
games today are made
using raster graphic approach.
And when you make a game
with that type of graphics,
you have a lot of textures.
And these textures will end up
taking up a large percentage
of your assets for your game.
They can be really big.
And then they're
also big once you
get them loaded into memory.
And also, there's this issue
of device fragmentation.
So a lot of different GPU
support different texture
formats, and they have different
quirks and different bugs
between them.
So if you use a lot
of raster graphics,
a lot of textures
in your game, you're
going to spend a lot of time
dealing with all those issues.
So the alternative to that
is to use vector graphics.
And vector graphics are really
awesome because your assets
will get a lot smaller
when you switch
to using vector graphics.
Because you're now just storing
the data, the instructions,
to tell the GPU how to do its
job, which is rasterization.
And as you can see with this
little dog character we have,
you're going to have
crisp, sharp graphics
no matter what resolution.
And this is really
important for mobile
to be able to have
your game, your app,
look crisp across all
different devices.
So we've been using vector
graphics in Dart for our game,
and we found it to be
a great fit in Dart.
For example, in
our editor, we're
able to actually use the DOM
SVG parser to parse SVGs for us
and import them into our editor.
So we got that
functionality right out
of the box with
the web platform,
and we didn't have to write any
code for that ourselves, which
was awesome.
So the next kind of big
challenge for making our game
is the issue of audio.
And there's actually a lot
of similarities between audio
and graphics in that
pre-rendered audio files
like WAV files, or
even compressed files
like MP3 or OGG, they'll take up
a lot of space in your assets,
again, just like textures.
And again, once you
get them loaded,
they're going to
take a lot of memory.
And you're also
going to have, again,
a lot of device fragmentation.
Different devices will support
different audio formats.
They'll have different
native sampling rates.
And you're going to deal
with a lot of device issues
again if you go that route.
So we decided we wanted to have
a similar solution to what we
had for graphics and render our
audio dynamically at runtime.
And to do that, we wanted
to use the MIDI protocol.
So when I first say
MIDI, you probably
have some idea in your
mind of what that is.
And it's probably
similar to what
we had when we first started
thinking we might use it.
But in reality,
MIDI is a protocol
for describing musical data.
And like when we
use vector graphics
and we're just storing
the instructions
to tell the GPU how
to draw, with MIDI,
we're able to just store the
instructions in the data that
tell the device how to
render the audio at runtime.
So our assets get a
lot smaller again,
and we avoid a lot of
that device fragmentation
because the device is going to
render the audio in a format
that it can deal with.
So the Dart and the web
platform really aligned
with this solution for us
because of the web MIDI
standard, which is now
available in Chrome.
And you can access
that from Dart.
So again, we found
the web platform
to be really appealing
here for our audio.
And so the last challenge
I'd like to talk about
is this issue of simulation.
And a lot of game
development workflows
that I've used in
the past have dealt
with artists and
designers creating
assets for the game in kind
of some standalone editors
which will export files,
and then those files
will typically go through
some build process and create
a binary package,
which they then
load into some standalone
desktop emulator for OpenGL ES.
And then they can see the
results of their change running
in the game.
Now, the problem
with that approach
is that as the number
of assets in your game
gets larger and larger, there's
time between when an artist
or designer can make
a change to when
they can see the effect of that
change running in the game.
It gets longer and longer.
So we knew that we wanted
a much tighter edit refresh
cycle similar to what
web developers have
when there doing their work.
So this is where
the web platform
became attractive to us
again, because it's built
to do these types of things.
And WebGL 1.0 is
basically the same thing
as OpenGL ES 2.0,
which is what you
want to use probably if you're
making a game for mobile.
So what we actually did was
develop our game engine in Dart
first.
And we were able to
do a lot of iterations
just in this simulation
environment building our engine
and get it solid and working
the way we want to it to.
And then later, port that in a
pretty straightforward manner
to native mobile platforms.
So just to show you
one small advantage
of having this
simulation environment,
an issue that mobile
game developers
would be quite familiar
with is this issue
of losing the graphics context.
So it can pretty much
happen at any time.
And you want your game to be
able to react to that event
and recover without the
user noticing, basically.
So I'm going to just see if I
can lose the graphics context.
And wow, you see
that my presentation
has gone blank here.
So I'll see if I can restore it.
Cool.
So I'm going to
leave full-screen,
and maybe we can see
what's going on here.
So actually, our
presentation has been running
in our simulator here in Dart.
And you can see behind
it, we have our editor.
So these two windows
are a Chrome app
that's written in Dart.
And probably one of the first
things you might want to know
is which technologies
or packages we
used to build this GUI.
So in the editor
here, I'll show you.
OK, so one thing we
really love about Dart
is that it makes it easy
for us to work directly
with the platform.
We didn't really want to
use a lot of frameworks.
And with Dart, we can work
directly with the Dart HTML
library and be very productive.
So actually,
everything you see here
is just written with Dart HTML.
And in the middle,
it's a WebGL canvas.
And then the property
grid and the file tree
are all just custom elements.
And actually, though the
property grid here and the file
tree are open source on
GitHub and [? Pub. ?]
So you can explore the code and
see how we built those, or even
use them yourself if you like.
So that's our editor.
And I'm going to pass
it back to Arturs,
and he's going to show you a
bit of how we use this tool.
ARTURS VITOLS: So I'm back.
So we're going to create a
simple level in our editor.
So we're going to just grab a
pencil, adjust the view a bit.
And you can see how
we're drawing a level.
Wow, it's like-- and I'm
drawing a Bezier curve here.
So I have enabled
the debug mode.
And let's adjust some knobs.
Let's change the
color some here.
So this would be a practical
terrain for the level.
So we would need
some spawn point.
We would define where we
will have a span point.
For that, that we have items.
As you can see, I'm
rolling, but it's
a huge list of items you have.
And here's a scripted
item called spawn point.
You can see the script
is attached here.
You can just double-click
it and put it in the scene.
Let's place it here.
So we have a spawn point,
so we need a finish line.
So we just grab a finish line.
This is the same
object as scripts.
And put it up here in the
hill, and just hit Play
and see what's going on.
And we have our character.
The sun is shining.
I'm going to hit Play.
And he can jump around, but
the finish line is too high.
We can't get there.
So we're going to
use the full power
of edit [? reverse cycle ?]
in our editor.
And we're just going to
draw here a small island
to help us out.
OK, just need some adjustments.
I hope it won't be too close.
I'll just hit Play and
see again what's going on.
So now we can get higher,
but it's still not enough.
So we need some tool-- ah.
It was-- yeah, almost got there.
So we can add interactive items.
So let's add this brown object.
You'll see what
it can do for us.
Let's add it here.
I hope I'll get there.
So I'll just hit Play.
And let's jump again.
And yay.
[APPLAUSE]
Woo.
We got to the finish line.
So now, I'm going to show
you the complete level, how
it looks in the editor.
I'm going to load
our [? work ?] file.
So let's go to the
scene, select level.
Let's do seven.
Yes.
So here, you an see a
complete scene in our editor.
This is without debug mode.
If I enable the debug
mode, it looks like this.
So for you, I'm
going to disable it
so you can enjoy the
full view of the scene.
The other about
think about using
SVG is that you can
dynamically change colors.
So right now, we have all assets
prepared in purple and blue.
But let's say we
want a night scene.
So we just swap
the color palettes,
and we have a night
here going on.
So we're going to play a
bit this level to show you
how it looks from inside.
We're going to start out
here in the dungeons,
and we're going to
try to get up here.
I'm not sure I'm going
to get there because this
is a very hard level.
Let's do it full screen.
Yeah.
So we're going to refresh.
OK.
So let's go switch the cards.
So for this event, to
celebrate this event,
we actually added a Dart mobile.
[APPLAUSE]
And for a couple of days, it's
will be, for in-game coins--
you have to collect
coins in the level.
And for a couple of
days, we're going
to leave to just 100
coins if anybody wants
to buy it and play around.
Later on, it will
be harder to unlock.
So just unlock it.
Let's go have some fun.
We are actually on
the wrong level.
This is not the
one I showed you.
So we're going to
use privileges.
Because this is
developer's mode,
it actually can go into
levels that are not unlocked.
So I'm cheating.
So this is the level I
showed you, the castle scene.
OK.
So here, you see the game.
Ah.
Oh, boy.
I can do this.
OK.
Here's one nasty robot.
OK, this one is-- when
you get on the edge,
he always gets you.
You're going to find that out if
you're going to play the game.
Yeah.
Yeah, probably
you've seen enough.
Let's return to
our presentation.
I'm going to load back
the presentation file now.
So yeah, this is
presentation file.
I'm going to hit
Play, second part.
Full screen, refresh,
second part again.
So in the beginning, I talked
about performance goals.
So the question is,
did we reach our goals?
The first challenge
for us was memory.
So we wanted the app to
be below 20 megabytes.
So right now, the game is
somewhere around 13 megabytes.
When you have installed
it, the actually APK size
is somewhere around 7 megabytes.
So we get that challenge.
The performance
challenge-- the goal
was to run on my phone, which
has single-core 1 gigahertz
CPU.
And actually, we're even running
the game on single core 600
megahertz CPU, and it runs fine.
It's playable.
And the loading time,
we wanted to be fast.
In the end, we ended up
putting a 2 second delay
in the splash screen.
It's the one when you see a
logo when you open the app.
We needed to put a 2
second the delay in it
so you could actually
see the splash screen.
Otherwise, it was just splash.
It would do what
it's supposed to do.
It would splash you.
And we have no loading
time between levels.
About unique look, so
because we're using SVGs,
and there's a weird mixture of--
nice mixture with SVGs and 3D.
As you saw, the carts
were actually in 3D,
and some other background
objects are in 3D.
And yeah, because we
use this weird mixture
and different colors, I kind of
think we achieved unique look.
But there are no
measurements for that.
I can't measure that.
And the unique feel,
for these last two,
we have no measurements.
So probably, we have to go
to the Google Play Store
to find it out.
Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]
MALE SPEAKER 1: Oh my gosh.
I'm want to play
with your dev tools.
Can we buy your dev tools?
Not we, Google.
I'll get in trouble for that.
But like--
ARTURS VITOLS: Dev tools?
MALE SPEAKER 1: I
want to build a level.
That looks so much fun.
ARTURS VITOLS: We can work
some-- it's negotiable.
It's negotiable.
MALE SPEAKER 1: Do you
have any feature requests?
ARTURS VITOLS:
Like, if you-- no.
MALE SPEAKER 1:
Wasn't that amazing?
Beautiful.
We have about two, three
minutes for questions?
MALE SPEAKER 2: We can do a
couple minutes of questions.
ARTURS VITOLS: We
have to ask Ross.
He's programmer.
I'm just designer.
MALE SPEAKER 2:
Questions anyone?
All the way in the back.
Yes, you, the one
who's looking confused
if I'm pointing at you.
I am pointing at you.
AUDIENCE: You can hear me?
MALE SPEAKER 1:
Yes, I can hear you.
MALE SPEAKER 2: We'll
repeat your question.
AUDIENCE: Yes, in
terms of [INAUDIBLE]
I'd imagine to Android
and iOS, what were
your estimates [INAUDIBLE]?
MALE SPEAKER 2: OK, so
what was your time estimate
for porting code, from running
in the simulator to running
in native OpenGL
ES on Android, iOS?
Did I get that right?
AUDIENCE: Yep.
MALE SPEAKER 2: Yes.
ROSS SMITH: OK, so yeah, our
native engine is in C++ so that
we can run it on Android
or iOS or other platforms.
So adding new platforms, once
we have that native engine,
can be done in one or two
months as an estimate.
But to build out that
engine the first time,
we spent about four months
to do the initial port.
ARTURS VITOLS: With we,
he wants to say he did it.
He was the only
one working on it.
ROSS SMITH: But it was
fairly straightforward.
I mean, things just take time.
But there were no major
issues that popped up.
Going from the WebGL
to the OpenGL ES 2.0,
it was really quite smooth.
MALE SPEAKER 2: Same person
has another question.
AUDIENCE: I was
just [INAUDIBLE].
MALE SPEAKER 2: Oh, OK.
Cool.
MALE SPEAKER 1: And
obviously, you guys
will be around to answer
questions and other things?
ARTURS VITOLS: Yep.
MALE SPEAKER 1:
Super exciting stuff.
Absolutely amazing.
Thanks for coming out, guys.
ROSS SMITH: Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]